this is the way i describe it it's the
ivory tower yeah and
a bunch of people brought a bowl to the
front door and up in the top was hillary
clinton the democrats looking down
laughing and scoffing sipping their wine
and then the the right-wing populists
let go of the ropes and the ball went
boom
right through the door and they've been
screaming for years as the bowl rampages
around
but for the people down below
everything's getting better
yeah and so they're like the way i
describe it to like my progressive
friends i'm like listen man
they i that friend i was talking you
about who was telling me that they
didn't think trump could win
they hate joe biden my friend she hates
joe biden
she was saying joe biden's awful they're
corporate democrats they don't care
they're saying whatever they think
people want to hear and i said
let trump clear out the ivory tower
don't let the establishment back in
because they will lock the doors up
double barricade them and you will never
have another chance
trump is rampaging around and they're
panicked freaking out falling apart joe
biden
is is crumbling and they're losing
control
trump does four more years and there
will be no more democratic establishment
there will just be the progressive
populists and the right-wing populists
and then they won't be standing in your
way that's how i feel
yeah i mean i don't blame i'm trying to
i'm trying to put myself in the shoes of
a progressive activist too and
i it's i think that's the other thing
that's uh not lost on the progressives
don't give away i think a lot's lost on
them but one of the things that's not
lost on them is that like
they're kind of corporatist overlords
and nancy pelosi and joe biden and
people who've been in washington for 40
years like
they don't actually care right and like
they're they're really good at acting
like they care and i think joe
joe biden i think is is someone who's
really really good at expressing really
like i'll find like i won't assume
malice here like i think he's really
good at showing individual empathy
but i think it's really really hard to
look at his voting record and say yeah
you know what
this guy cares and has been fighting for
everyday americans and i don't know
who's been kicking around washington as
long as he has who you can genuinely
look at and say you know what that
person has done since day one
they've done the hard things they've
fought the fights they've fought the
unpleasant ones
other than to be clear bernie sanders
who i can't stand
it's what he's done he's done it so the
reason why i want to bring up the story
from the oc actress is because i watched
the video
and i don't know if they pull up the the
exact quote but one of the most
interesting things she says
if you think that you know
she basically said you've got joe biden
hillary clinton kamala harris who have
been in politics for decades
they created the systemic racism you're
complaining about
you can't vote for them and let them
stay in that you're you're part of the
problem
and that's that's that's how i feel
about particularly kamala harris
joe biden come on 47 years the crime
bill he did a bunch of really bad things
he's been criticized for by a lot of
people
including como harris including kamala
harris and it's shocking to me that you
have progressives that hate trump
more it's like but they're like trump's
a fascist it's the end of the world i'm
like the democrat
the corporate establishment types are
telling you that because they don't want
trump to win
trump has a lot of things trump is not a
fascist and trump in my opinion
if i've often said if you took a a
person identical to trump
and cleaned up the act oh they'd win a
landslide absolutely if you if you took
away the
if you took away all of the like all of
the things that made him donald trump
the
reality tv show star right the the the
the billy bush video the marriages the
divorces the comments about women like
the interview like
if you take him being the kind the type
of chummy guy who can go on howard stern
and say
some really vile awful things and put
like a little bit of makeup on it
you're right you're right i mean he
would he would run away it wouldn't be
close because there wouldn't be
there wouldn't be anyone and like here
i'm not i'm not gonna you know lie to
anybody i was a
very never trump guy in 2016 for mostly
all of those reasons
right i wanted someone with dignity and
character and christian values and
respect and whatever and whatever you
think of donald trump he's not those
things
no and if you could just if you could
just kind of like take those little
pieces and just
stick them in here and stick him in
there you're right he'd it would be like
rick and he'd win
but compare him to biden now yeah i mean
and that's that's the thing too like
you look at biden and it's he's he walks
the walk he talks to talk he does it
well he's a politician
and it's just that unfortunately what's
gonna happen to him is the same thing
that happened with hillary clinton
donald trump is specifically designed
it's like he was he wasn't made in a lab
to appease people like me he wasn't he
wasn't
he wasn't made in a lab to appease a lot
of different voters but you know what he
was made in the lab to do his true
superpower
is he is a perfect foil for joe biden or
hillary clinton or kamala harris or
nancy pelosi
or anyone who has spent too much time
acting like a politician
he's perfectly built for you couldn't
ask for anything else and so the idea of
the rock through a window makes so much
sense
i think to millions and millions of
americans because they look and they're
like you know what fine
well-dressed nice talking joe biden fine
i'm sure i would like to sit down and
have a fireside chat with him but if i
want to get something done
he's got 47 years hasn't done it there's
there's there's so many different things
about trump that
push him over uh joe biden it's like one
way i can describe it is you got sleepy
joe and you got bombastic trump
but if you're talking about foreign
policy defending this country then
you've got the big bully
who pushes everyone around and won't
shut up or the guy who's very
you know sleepy yeah the the people who
are going to be focused on military
strength are going to look at trump and
be like i would like the bully to work
for me
yeah if you've got people who want just
trade deals and trade arrangements
why would they go for joe biden who the
you know the obama administration was
pro-trans-pacific partnership yep
bernie sanders was against that so the
populist left anne wright agree on these
trade agreements
yeah but when i when i said compare
trump to biden now i'm saying just like
across the board biden doesn't cut it
he's he's bottom tier and it's it's it's
due to a lot of things i mean first of
all biden's history is really bad yeah
the things he's voted for the things
he's said and his his has passed gaffes
his lies
he's been called out for but now he's
also just
he needs to retire yeah with all due
respect you know joe biden is well past
his prime a long time ago yeah
and and and seeing some of the the
things he tries to say
what gets me is how the how the
journalists complete the sentences for
him
when he tries giving an idea and then he
fumbles and says gibberish
they'll actually write a complete
sentence yeah and i'm like you can't do
that
he didn't say the same it's insane he
didn't say so you look at donald trump
and i look at uh you know joe biden
negotiating with many of the
progressives
and he's not giving them everything they
want right but he's doing enough while
also i think you know the town hall the
other day he was kind of throwing
throwing him under the bus
showing that it was a it was a uh the
whole thing was a lie
right yeah basically he was like we're
pro these progressive things we're going
to fight for with bernie sanders
and then came out and said no screw all
that we're we're here for pennsylvania
and we're yeah exactly
what they want and he does this too so
one of the one of the more interesting
ones i think lately has been fracking
so exactly so biden has flipped i think
four times now in the last couple of
weeks about fracking and so originally
his his position was
he was pro fracking he understands it's
important you're in a place like
pennsylvania like this is important jobs
it's low-cost energy there's a lot of
different benefits to it
one two then he got asked by the
progressives and they were like
uh he's like oh well no there's no place
there's no place for fossil fuels
and then a journalist clarified somebody
somebody had asked him a fellow question
like
well what does that mean for for
fracking he's like we won't have that in
a bite administration
and then he came back he walked it back
again and said oh no no like he's
speaking pennsylvania or something and
so he's got it
and the thing is the journalists give
him cover every time
every time there's no there's no pull it
a fact there's no there's no four
pinocchios for these sorts of things
they're bald-faced obvious lies
that none of the people whose most
important job to the american people
which is to call out lies
all of a sudden lose interest them yeah
and i think about all the people who are
watching youtube
when i was talking to those uh dentists
well i shouldn't say i was talking i was
going all right
getting you know dental workouts like
biden talk but these are people talking
about the youtube videos they watched
and that's why they go after youtube
that's why they're pro-censorship
yeah you know it's really crazy a lot of
people have been getting knocked off
youtube and various social media
platforms in the past
uh several couple weeks it's been
intense and this is something we all
predicted
if you thought 2018 was bad wait until
the presidential election they have to
get rid of every single conservative
every single right-wing pro-trump
and i'm surprised i'm still here to be
honest although oh we got a cat he's
going to steal your water oh that's okay
i hope you can share water we can share
water but but yeah i i noticed that
most the people i talked to that have
flipped for trump yeah they're people
who tell me they started to do their own
research
every single story i hear from someone
who walked away from the democratic
party
yeah it's it's very simple they said i
heard all of these things i believed
them
and then one day i decided to do my own
research and then i watched uh you know
a lot of people are like i watched one
trump speech and then realized hey wait
a minute
yeah they everything they said was a lie
yeah and these things slowly unravel too
so i think for
for me one of the one of the big moments
was um
it was the steel dossier right and so i
remember like you
when it first came out everyone was in
uniform agreement you got this dirty
dossier like oh
trump's finished there's all these
problems blah blah blah blah blah and i
bought it i looked at it i was like oh
wow like
mi5 guy like he's he's well respected
whatever i'm sure he's great fine
and i i bought it and i remember i i
peeled back
one day because it was when the the
story came out that someone had alleged
that
trump had been a russian asset since
1987.
all right this is this is my moment i
was like hands up i can't
no no no no no no no no no no no no i'll
i'll i'll believe a lot of things that
may not make a lot of sense but this is
not one of those such things
and i think you did you have a lot of
people who are asking a lot of questions
i think there's a lot of good work on
the right of people who are submitting
foia requests
and who are asking the right questions
and so because of that you do start to
have people who get this information
that filters through and starts to break
through
the lockdown that you have that is that
is mainstream media
when i was talking to my progressive
friend you know uh
she was giving me all of the mainstream
media talking points that were devoid of
any fact or reason
yeah and we had a good conversation i i
consider to be a good friend
it was really amazing to me actually
that she could believe a lot of things
she did supporting critical race theory
disagreeing with trump
defending some of the things said by a
lot of these far leftists
and we had we had a discussion and
argument about it but one
you know she said a couple things like
for one she said kyle rittenhouse is a
white supremacist who traveled across
state lines to hunt down peaceful
protesters and i was like whoa whoa whoa
whoa
whoa and so i think if you're coming
from
politics from this point of view based
upon
the mainstream media's lies yeah and i
say mainstream media it's really hard to
break down it's political operatives who
work within media good point yeah
because
i still use the new york times for
sourcing in many different ways yeah
yeah
yeah he he really wants you i know he's
very very committed i'll put it here so
he can have something he can't he can't
he can't get to it oh yeah that's why
he's not gonna get in there but yeah i
mean
i hear you and like i agree and don't
forget for written house it wasn't just
your progressive friend like ayanna
presley said that
right and so i i think it is it is very
very easy i know
it's it's gonna not get it's it can be
really easy
you repeat something even devoid of any
facts or meaning you repeat it until it
becomes true for all intents and
purposes
right and so if you keep repeating the
idea that the steele dossier is credible
or you keep repeating over and over
again that written house is a white
supremacist
all you have to do is say it enough
times and eventually you get there
i can't stop laughing because he's just
jamming his face in the jar and it's
just it's just not quite going to fit
this is why we let him on the show
because he's he's the comic relief for
all the
despair and violence we could use that
today i mean seriously seriously no i
did think about a lot of people are like
you know it's always news is always such
a downer it's always so negative
no no he'll knock it over you just yeah
he'll
just just give him a little just don't
let him spill it
so uh anyway to clear to clarify my
point in the mainstream media
you know like i was saying there's a lot
of sources that i still use but you have
to be very careful you got to fact check
it
but if you start your your political
journey specifically from i read a story
that said kyle written house is a white
supremacist
well then you're going to agree with
critical race theory right so one of the
things she said to me was um
don't you realize that there's like a
very serious problem with police
targeting minority communities
and i said let me ask you a question and
i'll ask you this question
do you know how many unarmed black men
were shot and killed last year is it
eight
thirteen ah okay and then i said do you
know how many police interactions there
were
right my understanding is there was 33
375 million
so out of all of those interactions 13
unarmed bill dad i will tell you this
those are individual cases that need to
be explored to make sure there was no
wrongdoing because a loss of life is one
of the most egregious
violations of civil liberties and civil
rights but it doesn't sound to me like
there is this massive widespread problem
right or like i think it was it was
lebron james was the one who had the
great quote where he said it's open
season on black men in america
right and there's this narrative of you
know not only is there
it's open season on black men in america
and police and white people can kill
black people without consequence and
without issue
that's just not true right like there's
no there's no reading of the literature
that can make that something a point
that can be justified and stand on its
own
like it's an absurd thing it's a
conspiracy theory but beyond it
it just gets repeated so many times that
people are like oh yeah like they're
of course there are because the numbers
don't matter you know
and and one of the one of the things i
like to bring up all the time even
though it feels fruitless
uh like pointless is that they complain
all day night about q and on
and you know alex jones he gets banned
from the internet all of these things
yet they screech uh so you're referring
to jonathan chait on msnbc
when he said chris hayes the famous
chris hayes millions of followers
has a guy in his show who says now this
we can't prove this but
donald trump may have been a russian
asset since the 1980s
and i just started laughing i'm like you
really believe this stuff
listen man and the moon could be made of
cheese yes exactly like okay listen
could donald trump be a russian asset
yes he could it is in the realm of
reality unlike the moon being made of
cheese i'll give him that one fine
but to start from like to in order to
get that far i gotta tell you man
911 as an inside job sounds much more
plausible than donald trump secretly
working as a russian agent to subvert
america
right and and having it succeed right
like the the
the premise of what jonathan shade is
saying is that we we live in a universe
where
for the last what is that 33 years
the russians the soviets the soviets
whose entire country then disbanded and
they kept this act up
right and they managed to they managed
to move along this manchurian candidate
through the new york city celebrity
scene
and then eventually run him for
president and have him win
win the presidency almost there like 40
years later like do these people
hear themselves even a little bit like
it's it's
so far beyond the realm of possibility
that and and here and if you want to
make the q a compar
comparison too the idea that there is a
global cabal of people
wealthy people particularly liberal
donors who are
uh raping and assaulting children is a
lot more believable
i think there's a lot more evidence on
the books that that is something that
exists than trump
russia now to go to the more extreme
elements of some of these conspiracies
about like the satan
you know yeah the cold stuff it it it
does get in into the into the crazy
realm
for sure but look we've got a dude who
had an island
and uh uh he had a lot of friends in a
lot of high places who traveled to that
island and we know about this we have
witness testimony
a witness claimed bill clinton had
visited the island so
there actually is court documents and
witness testimony saying hey this stuff
might be happening
now of course you might get conspiracy
theorists who take that and turn it into
this ridiculous and more extreme
conspiracy about
you know superhero trump fighting an
evil globalist whatever
with tiny breadcrumbs it's it's like
irobot right yeah tiny little
breadcrumbs that lead you to the
conclusion and only if you're paying
close attention but
but it is uh you are correct it is uh
absolutely correct to say that
the russia gate conspiracy stuff is
a full order of magnitude more insane
yeah and it's still
adam schiff just tweeted we got a new
whistleblower complain about russian
interference and blah blah blah and it's
like here we go again
yeah it's it's non-stop with these
people about the conspiracy theories
they they they make things up they push
them with impunity
right because they control the media and
everyone just reacts to whatever the
media says and what i mean by the media
i just mean
high-profile news organizations like the
new york times you know
tom cotton writes an op-ed saying send
in the troops
they they write multiple apologies then
there's a staff revolt
then the guy resigns the the editor
resigns do do you see the thing about
newsweek
where this professor wrote that kamala
harris might not be eligible for i
for the office see that yeah and then
newsweek issued i think like seven
apologies i believe that i totally
believe that they
they pulled down real quick they were
like editor's note we did not mean to
imply editor's note again we really feel
editor's note again
editors note again and then finally they
did a whole new write-up explaining
the conversation because the me because
they got attacked by leftist activists
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you